a lot of american cakes they're like oh
let's do cream cheese frosting why
who told you that was okay
[Music]
i don't see why i wouldn't like mexican
cakes i haven't met a culture's cakes
that i don't like and maybe even spicy
kind of like mexican candy
this looks amazing it's pretty also
smells incredibly sweet no this is
healthy cake i can eat this and i feel
guilty because there's fruit in it it's
so soft that you don't even know you're
like eating a lot of cake it's gonna be
so moist but look at like i hate that
word you don't like that word
i think we as a society need to get past
not liking the word moist i can eat this
all day solid that's pretty damn good
cake
cinnamon toast crunch smell like i'm
gonna try to squeeze the liquid out of
it it's like seriously soggy kinda like
a churro it's really sweet
wow this is
where it's at it's a cake that'll hold
you at night like it's a great cake
[Music]
it takes a hit really well it holds up
like an american cake would just crumble
it's definitely like milk in this this
is the wettest one by far might just be
milk and i'm lactose intolerant
why are you here i think all of these
are milk we're getting extremely wet i
feel like you could bathe in this cake
it's got a good flavor like you don't
have to question this cake so it's a
reliable cake it's a relax it's a cake
you can depend on
it smells kind of like coffee and it has
three layers
talk about fancy this feels like an
adult cake
the others feel like cakes for kids this
is like you have an adult party with
wine this is like the kind of cake that
you eat in bed at night when you're like
a little sad and you're like [ __ ] it and
then like you happy cry cause the cake
is so good
i think mexican cakes are the way to go
these cakes were bomb they were very
original i may never have a regular cake
ever again i might have to just have
mexican cake like the best cake i've
ever had probably my mouth's still
watering from the cakes i'm trying to
hold back drool
[Music]
foreign